hello everyone if you're a fan of scp
explained you'll know that we regularly
post interesting questions in our
community tab asking for responses from
you our dear fans these have ranged from
questions about specific anomalies like
scp-096
or your suggestions on how we should
actually kill
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile
we've even asked you which anomalous
powers you'd want to have and pose your
questions directly to scp-343
also known as god and of course the
terrifying and infamous scarlet king but
in our latest community question asking
you about hypothetical crossovers
between the scp foundation and the weird
wild multiverse of all fiction you truly
outdid yourself with thousands upon
thousands of responses and we thought
rather than just making one video
selecting our favorites we'd turn each
of our favorites into whole videos and
how are we going to do that
that's where this wonderful
state-of-the-art gizmo comes into play
you may remember the anomatron 6000 our
incredibly advanced artificial
intelligence driven supercomputer
designed specifically to run simulations
for the scp foundation we fed this
computer data from countless scp
foundation experiments and cross tests
and all the data from your suggestions
this will allow the fine folks at the
scp foundation to explore any anomalous
hypothetical without risking the lives
of staff members or civilians this
brings us to our first simulation
suggested in a huge number of comments
could
scp-682 be contained within the back
rooms for those not in the know the
backrooms is an internet urban legend
that spiraled into a full-blown
phenomenon it's built on the premise
that if you're not careful and enter
certain specific circumstances you can
no clip out of our reality and enter a
terrifying multi-level alternate reality
where you're stalked by a variety of
bizarre and frightening creatures this
could be a complete nightmare for your
average person but how would it play out
if
scp-682 the endlessly angry hard to
destroy reptile found its way inside
also for another backrooms related
surprise stick around until the end of
the video in the meantime though let's
boot up the anomatron and test this new
scenario the worst had happened again
scp-682 had busted out of containment
during a cross-test and started making a
b-line for the nearest populated area
several helicopters containing heavily
armed mtf new seven hammer down members
were in hot pursuit attempting to slow
the vicious reptile down with targeted
sniper fire at its legs but it seems
that these efforts were all for naught
scp-682 had already reached the defunct
industrial district on the edge of a
nearby city and if the beast managed to
actually reach a populated area all hell
would break loose that's when they
pulled out the heavy weaponry miniguns
mounted to the helicopters unleashed a
reign of hellfire down onto scp-682
however 682 managed to dodge most of the
bullets and simply tank the rest command
authorized the use of heavy ornaments
the helicopters missile launchers they'd
pick up the pieces afterwards once
scp-682 was back in containment however
the reptile had plans of its own it
charged into a nearby abandoned chemical
plant to avoid the gunfire from above
this was exactly what hammerdown wanted
the helicopters circled around the
chemical plant and unleashed a barrage
of powerful incendiary missiles blowing
the plant to kingdom come in hopes of
dragging an incapacitated 682 out of the
rubble afterwards but when the smoke had
cleared and only the rubble was left 682
was nowhere to be seen even for the
hardcore operatives of hammer down this
caused an anxiety spike had it tunneled
into the ground had it adapted to the
attack by turning invisible or getting
tiny to escape they'd done all these
things before or after all the deranged
attempts at putting scp-682 in the
ground had some light firebombing killed
the monster whatever the case they need
to search in case scp-682 popped up
somewhere else and started causing havoc
if it was still alive which it probably
was they couldn't rest on their laurels
until they'd found it again meanwhile
scp-682 woke up it felt groggy and
irritated its body resting against an
unpleasant soggy carpet it licked the
carpet the moisture had the distinct
flavor of human spinal fluid which 682
had tasted many times before the sickly
yellow walls and incessant buzzing from
the fluorescent lights up above were
nauseating and it gave 682 a nagging
headache this only made 682's default
emotion blistering rage and hatred even
worse it began walking around exploring
the strange spatial anomalous
environment was this more of that
frustrating foundation trickery another
one of those pure isle cross tests the
last thing 682 remembered was running at
one of the walls in the chemical plant a
wall that in hindsight seemed darker
than all the others but rather than
shattering through the brickwork it was
here now in this strange tacky lobby
that never seemed to end it was like a
kaleidoscope of empty 1990s office
kitsch endless worthless yellow walls
arranged like some labyrinthian
nonsensical maze leading nowhere and
devoid of all life as scp-682 wandered
through it and of course
scp-682 found it disgusting it was only
on level zero and already 682 hated the
back rooms just as much as it hated our
dimension someone or something had to
pay for the crime of inconveniencing it
this way and it would happily turn this
whole dimension inside out just to find
some beings to kill inside it yes
that would be great fun
scp-682 began its frantic search for an
exit evolving an innate sonar ability
and picking up speeds that would be
impossible for human beings this is the
part where most people would go mad or
die from hunger or thirst
scp-682 not so much it could keep
searching and searching and searching
until the stars burned out in the sky it
would find its prey
somehow and when it did it would put
them through hell and as it turned out
this new universe rewarded 682's dog's
stubbornness because when it passed
through a seemingly random hallway after
hours of searching it was in a different
place entirely this place looked like
some huge abandoned warehouse complex
with water shining off the ground if 682
had more advanced knowledge of the back
rooms he would have known this was level
one but the only number scp-682 cared
about was body count and in that regard
it would find level one to be a vast
improvement two groups of humans had
established bases in this level of the
back rooms the major explorer group a
faction of professional backrooms
travelers who maintained their base
alpha on this level in the back room's
non-aligned trade group a commercial
group whose primary base is an economic
hub on this very level a fortified
city-like area with a population of 412
which would a few hours after 682's
appearance be a population of zero but
before all of that it felt like grabbing
a bite at the diner tom's diner is a
refuge for many people trapped in the
back rooms a casual eatery nestled into
the cold warehouse environment of level
one where people could get a warm meal
from tom a former cook who's been
trapped in the back room for years
scp-682 was eager to be part of this
grand tradition but the hard to destroy
reptile decided to buck the trend a
little by just devouring tom himself
from there it decided to launch its rage
fuel defensive against the various
humanoid inhabitants of the level both
the major explorer group-based alpha and
the backroom's non-aligned trade group
tradekeep were heavily fortified against
the kind of entities these folks had
gotten used to facing in the back rooms
but they were completely unprepared for
a creature of
scp-682's sheer power intelligence
endurance and ferocity the scp
foundation had been studying the
creature for decades with far more
resources than either of these two
backrooms bound groups and they still
had a hard time keeping the beast
consistently contained sadly for the
great bastion of human hope in the back
rooms
scp-682 swept through both outposts in a
matter of hours killing everyone there
without an ounce of remorse the only
person there it took its time with was
the final human being left in the
decimated remains of the major explorers
group base alpha it grabbed the man by
the throat and squeezed asking with its
guttural growling voice
you
were you when your dead brethren allied
with the scp foundation
despite a sphere the explorer told 682
that he had never heard of the scp
foundation nor did he know what kind of
entity 682 was um
then what is this place tell me and i
might give you a quick death the
explorer gave as good a response as he
could 682 was trapped in the back rooms
a multi-leveled interdimensional
nightmare filled with dangerous
creatures that made 682 curious
dangerous creatures that could make an
interesting challenge 682 asked the
explorer how could access these other
levels and find these creatures and the
explorer explained that through
exploring these levels enough anyone
could no clip into the next one it
really was that simple with that 682
knew all it needed to know and
carelessly murdered the final human
being of level one it had killed so many
humans over its long and twisted life it
was no different from breathing air now
an utterly perfunctory action it was
eager to discover these other creatures
on the lower levels and teach them a new
level of fear they'd never experienced
682 stormed the halls until it achieved
the next successful no clip into level 2
which manifested as a series of old
dilapidated maintenance tunnels that
seemed to stretch on for millions of
miles wonderful there were humans here
too apparently but who cared about them
this was the first level to feature a
smorgasbord of entities ripe for the
killing it sped through the tunnels
teeth and fangs born eager to deal death
with gleeful abandon the first entities
it encountered in the expansive tunnels
of level 2 were a collection of beings
known as crawlers insect-like creatures
infected with an extremely aggressive
fungal growth just getting close to them
could present an active risk to humans
not so much for a creature that could
easily regenerate after being tossed
into the sun as the creatures tried to
lunge as cp 682 simply crushed and
devoured them with little effort they
tasted a little stale on account of the
fungus but the chewiness was pleasing
hopefully there would be more
challenging foes down in the tunnel than
these mere insects
scp-662 thought to itself while
journeying deeper into the endless
network of tunnels soon enough scp-682
ventured into a section of the tunnel
engulfed in tuttle darkness its eyes
quickly adjusted developing immaculate
night vision that's when it spotted
another creature sharing this little
slice of darkness with it a pair of
floating glowing eyes and almost
cartoonish teeth grinning like some
maniacal looney tune this is an entity
known as a smiler and they're a
terrifying threat to any humans
venturing through the back rooms
scp-682 wasn't impressed it began a
perfect adaptation for the situation its
body began to glow emitting incredible
levels of both heat and light carving
through the darkness of the tunnel and
causing the smiler to emit a terrible
piercing shriek the sheer heat of this
new ability melted sections of the level
two tunnels around
scp-682 when the light finally dimmed
down to slightly more reasonable levels
where the smiler once stood was instead
a fizzling black scorch mod another
creature had painfully bitten the dust
and scp-682 was starting to have some
fun it took off further down into the
tunnels looking forward to finding its
next victim sadly for
scp-682 it wouldn't get to kill the next
set of victims a group of four child
facelifts spooky faceless little girls
who like to cut apart their typical
human victims with small objects were
wading a little further down the pipe
however when they felt scp-682
approaching they almost sensed the power
and cruelty of the beast coming towards
them even being little monsters
themselves game recognized game and they
knew that they needed to get the hell
out of there before the monster arrived
they climbed between the pipes on the
tunnel walls and skittered off into
hiding places deep in the dark
lucky for them
scp-682 passed them and just kept going
what would be the point in wasting time
on these little morsels when there were
apparently so many other creatures to
massacre down here next cp 682 came
across a truly pathetic creature
something that the mighty reptile
honestly felt a little embarrassed even
interacting with it was a creature known
as a clump a strange bundle of living
limbs that will move at great speeds and
attack its usually human targets it
tried to do the same to scp-682
maniacally flailing its many twisted
limbs 682 killed it in a single stomp
and moved on feeling its own
psychological equivalent of pity but not
that much of it not long after mercy
killing the clump
scp-682 came face to face with a series
of hounds mutant humanoids who travel on
all fours behaving in a wolf-like
fashion this would of course be the
stuff of nightmares for your average
human being but would far more likely
put a being like the heart to destroy
reptile to sleep with sheer boredom
humans acting like dogs that makes them
even more worthless the creature thought
as it charged forwards and began tearing
the group of hounds to shreds minutes
later it was splitting off into an
adjoining tunnel searching for more easy
entertainment but the deeper scp-682
made its way into the bowels of level 2
the more it approached a truly
horrifying realization the creatures it
was slaughtering here were even more
boring than the ones the scp foundation
ceaselessly threw at it back on its
native reality or at least the reality
where they'd contained it back in that
world it had faced giant flaming
demigods with swords hotter than the sun
it had faced some pale shrieking
monstrosity that didn't seem to die no
matter what the reptile threw at it
there was the dark gooey old man the
immortal warrior from the black coffin
and even the all-devouring bunny rabbit
here it was killing the same wretched
selection of beasts again and again a
truly pitiful offering was this really
the best this world had to offer
incidentally the next creature it found
was literally known as wretches by the
human inhabitants of the back rooms they
were fleshy zombie-like creatures that
scp-682 figured the sarcists back home
might enjoy they couldn't believe that
it was thinking fondly of that old place
while it carved the monsters to ribbons
with its claws it missed its old enemies
like dr bright dr cleff and even that
irritating yellow blob of snot the moore
tried to take its mind off the old world
by killing its way through this ant farm
of endless tunnels the more it found
itself waxing nostalgic for example
there were the plague goblins impish
little creatures with masks like that of
a plague doctor 682 found itself
thinking almost fondly about scp-049
while it listlessly ate the tiny
mischievous creatures like a depressed
person binging an extra large pack of
chips even their tiny squeaks as they
crunch between the reptile's terrible
teeth gave it no joy what a bleak turn
of events this had all turned out to be
as it wandered through the infinite
tunnels killing creatures and even
humans as it found them
scp-682 made a quiet promise to itself
somehow some way it would make its way
back to the universe it so recently
departed it would leave the back rooms
no matter how many levels a quiet
burning husk and return to the world of
fools and fiends that had taken for
granted all this time a visit to the
back rooms had taught the hard to
destroy reptile and all-too-human lesson
sometimes you don't know what you have
until it's gone sure the scp foundation
may have tried to kill it in a new
bizarre and increasingly sadistic way
every single day but that variety was
the spice of life it would return home
someday it knew that much but of course
a lot of creatures and people would need
to die before then but if that's what it
took well so be it
scp-682 licked its dagger-like fangs and
kept crawling if you want more of our
take on the bizarre liminal hell that is
the back rooms go check out our new
channel the back rooms explained for
more back rooms content in our signature
style now go check out scp-682 waze scp
foundation try to kill hard to destroy
reptile and scp-682 vs scp foundation
hard to destroy reptile termination
attempts for more of everyone's favorite
ordinary reptile